ladies and gentlemen we got the got the
cans on because today's the day
that cody confronts his biggest lie oh
to none other than
[Music]
what's up
welcome to the show man
how y'all doing we're good man how are
you
good good this is awesome yeah dude
thanks for coming on man uh just know
that for the rest of this interview we
will both be telling the truth okay
we'll make sure that's right
i'm gonna be telling the truth too i
can't wait
i can't wait well first of all before
jared gets in there cody go ahead okay
what oh
i'm sorry
i'm sorry for lying to you i just got
nervous yeah i guess i'm sorry for lying
too
yeah actually you lied too dawg i did i
did my my brain was playing some tricks
on me and um
i was sitting here at home my buddy's
like hey you see that uh podcast thing
they're talking about you i'm like what
are you talking about so he showed me it
now he was dying because i was i like i
told you quickly i was actually thinking
about it afterwards
like was he actually there
like yeah well he's well he said he was
so he had to be
you mementoed each other yeah we really
did here's the question though because a
lot of people are debating in the
comments like who's he thinking about
was my theory was it's jimmy tatro no so
i'll i'll tell you exactly what happened
okay so me and jimmy are good friends
and i know jimmy well and then i
obviously know who you are from real
bros of simi valley okay and my
girlfriend and i watch some of your
stuff and like we know who you are and
like you know we're fans of you and your
girlfriend and fiance i guess so now
i've been keeping up with it so
congratulations oh thanks dude yeah so i
saw you walk in and i was like oh
there's okay i know who that is and then
when you were walking by i was like i'll
say hi to him and like as i was going to
say hello i was like oh i've already met
him he was at that at the california
strong game he was there with jimmy and
it all kind of like just got confused in
my brain so i was like oh i've i've
already met him so i was like oh hey hey
cody i'm jared like i think we've
already met it was like all within like
a split second that i was like oh i've
already met him and then when you were
like oh yeah i was there i was like okay
well he was there okay good like it all
kind of it all kind of worked that way
and then after you had left i was like
wait was he actually there like and i
was looking at like i was thinking about
it i was like you know and obviously
jimmy and you are connected so there was
a little bit of confusion there but i i
guess my brain just told me that you
were there and and clearly you weren't
did either of you even go to mexico like
did you guys dream up that whole
situation as well did any of this
actually happen yeah yeah that's a real
question yeah did you ever think at any
point like afterwards like man he wasn't
there what a piece of [ __ ] no no no okay
okay not until i saw the podcast with
you guys you didn't think about it until
you watch the podcast and then you
realize oh that was a shitty thing he
did he was actually it was actually he
was saving me
exactly so it was actually a really
admirable thing to do right because if
you've been like if you'd been like no i
would have been like oh
never mind have a good day
so yeah no it was uh and my buddy was
like my buddy was there too so he was
like was he there and i was like
he said he was there so was your buddy
there at the game yeah yeah he was he
wasn't playing in it but he was there i
believe yeah gotcha yeah that's
hilarious that's really funny through
you just looking at each other like
right we all we're all boys right right
right
right we all shared a hot dog yeah
exactly one time i probably owe cody
thank you for for not embarrassing me in
front of some of my friends there oh joe
thank you jared your media training is
coming through like a shining stuff
seriously
i've done i've done a few of these yeah
i've had my uh fair share i got it this
is this is the most professional podcast
with tiny meat gang as the name oh thank
you man
it's uh it's really done well you guys
do a good job oh thank you thanks bro
yeah when you have small meat you have
to focus on other things you know
productions right yeah i i gotta thank
you for making me look cool in front of
my friends because as i said in the
episode they were all freaking out and
then the one guy that was with me
afterwards he was like
how do you know him i was like i don't
and likewise i didn't know you at the
time either
well listen i felt i felt so bad about
lying about a charity softball game that
i went on your website which by the way
what the [ __ ] is that url dude
dot store or something like that is that
anything
gg16.store.store
yeah that
is that a scam
store
i saw your donation thank you very much
i donated to the detroit lion foundation
because i
felt bad for lying about going to a
charity game nice you're going to lie
about the number you donated enough i
donated it was a million right
it was a million
thank you very much changing lives all
over the place it's changing lives yeah
if there ever is another charity
softball game where i buy something
you're going to be the first one invited
we should throw one that's what we
should do like yeah make one hand let's
do and tmg jared goff dude
yeah the actual charity softball game
yeah exactly yeah you can get tickets on
tmg
jtg.store and then um and then neither
of you will show up
but then we'll talk about it post yeah
exactly yeah god we raised so much money
that day yeah i'm glad we were able to
hash this out man thanks for coming on
the show we appreciate it man thank you
that was that was funny to watch i was
in tears watching it because i was like
oh my god that all makes sense now
and it is like the funny thing of like
you know we have mutual friends but like
we clearly didn't know each other i was
acting as if i did know you and and you
were acting as if you don't know
each other just trying to play it too
cool you know it's just too much la
going on yeah that's what it is if
anything
you know what that makes me think of
weirdly so i was at a restaurant and
margot robbie
uh walks in to get pickup and um that's
sick the whole well no just hold on
the whole room is like bugging out that
she's in there and this dude he like
he's like with his buddies and he kind
of like makes a gesture to his friends
in the vein of like watch this turns
around he's like hey she's like hi
he's like john
remember we uh and he just starts like
saying stuff he's like trying to
socially engineer her and he had her for
a second she was like yeah
no no i don't i don't think i think so
she didn't she didn't pull me she just
no she said no no it took her a second
what i'm saying is this is all just
saying like in la if you just do like
yeah no we met at the softball game if
you do that enough you can probably end
up at like elon musk's house i mean we
would know yeah yeah without actually
having yeah
i may actually use that on someone else
if i if i really don't know them yeah
like hey you know good to see you you
remember the softball game oh yeah yeah
or if they say no i'm like no you were
definitely there yeah yeah yeah yeah you
got to bully him into it no you were
there dude you made that big donation
dude good on you man you're the [ __ ]
man you're a nice guy yeah straight up
man hell yeah cody thank you for being
so nice for not embarrassing me and then
the donation you the man thank you man
really appreciate you coming on and good
to actually meet you as as as who we
think each other are exactly
fan of the show and fan of you guys so
keep it up you guys are doing great
thanks cody oh this is the other thing
you and i are actually business partners
and friday beers oh no way really
yes oh hell yeah did you invest i did oh
[ __ ] yeah i love those guys do you know
that you and i are like you and i are
like two of like four celebrity
investors whatever you want i wouldn't
call cody a celebrity but
i would definitely call you and their
podcast their podcast is coming out soon
and me and you are the first two
episodes let's go
well okay jared friend and now business
partner thanks for coming on the podcast
appreciate it
yeah see you soon thanks guys for having
me have fun of course later dude
all right
sweet all right that was fun that was
great um are you okay with keeping all
that investing in friday beers things in
or do you want us to cut early on yeah i
never invested in five years
are you serious i was about to and then
i didn't
are you serious
are you serious we're not rolling
dude we got that
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me what is
wrong with me why do i keep doing this
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro i need to [ __ ] that has to stay
here what is wrong with me
that is staying in
i'm [ __ ] dead
he did it again
[Laughter]
ryan fell to his [ __ ] knees
oh my god
[Laughter]
i i've been in la too long that's what
it is man like something's wrong dude
you even said new friend and business
partner now you like hammered it i
hammered it home what the [ __ ] is wrong
with [ __ ]
double down i was thinking in my head i
was like now i have to invest in order
to make this trip
i i don't blame you you looked right at
the camera went to my friend and
business partner
and you took the most confident drink
and he locked off and ryan's like are
you cool with that and you're like i
never existed
[Music]
i gotta get away for a while
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm sorry dude
i don't know i just there's no
i couldn't be more perfect you couldn't
script that
i was trying to make the show flow so i
had to say that
if i would have said no it would have
been like
no you're we're not business partners
and it would have been it would have
been the exact same as if i said no in
cabo
right
yes sir
i have no words i can only laugh
you